denn so machen so was raus
ja das stimmt nie wieder kommt dann
daraus wird nicht abfackeln alles viel
zu weit weg dafür so ich meins den
ersten test hast du ja ich kann die
hölle gehen da wo dies oxidieren ist
ich habe als ich jetzt reinfall übersät
schlechten pass auf dass da nix anfängt
zu brennen oder so das ist jetzt wichtig
ich denke schon die ganze zeit organs
dass ich da rein falle kennt er unsere
gefallen ich kenne deine dummheit das
ding rein schubs oder so kommen die du
dich total okay beim ich bin drin hat
man so viele szenen einfach rausnehmen
für sein best offenes regal es wirklich
so dick ist und es brennt aber nichts
anderes gut weil die server big mac
wer diesen typischen tv total videos 11
bei aldi zwei big macs über deine mutter
aber cool das ist jetzt mit den portalen
und so alles klappt unser haus ist
wunderschön es fertig hat ihm das ging
es mit knallt ja ich habe aus meiner
hand geschlagen
ich habe aus ihr mikro geschlagen als
trainer von seinem haus wie es jetzt
aussieht alter unser haus richtig geil
los also zumindest von ihnen von außen
sieht so ein bisschen schlicht aus
sondern von denen bis vor außenplätzen
von außen ist einfach das glas zu
verdammt ja ich bin noch auf dem weg was
brauchst muss danach mehr klar eine das
ja noch einmal lava ist es passiert aber
nichts die man machen macht das haus mal
von oben jetzt schön diese terrasse oder
so so jetzt das letzte mal so schön aus
wirklich wieder schön ist auch gar nicht
so schlecht ich würde es so machen dass
wir vielleicht doch hier also dass der
außenumsatz ging bleibt und dass wir
hier dann hier auch so was haben in
diesem viereck von von solches säule
unter wasser drin haben ja das kann man
nicht machen
das mache ich gut ich mach's du kannst
dich etwas anders kann man geht mir das
mal was aufgesammelt hat der gute idee
und hier will ich dann so machen wir das
so machen dass die säule noch hinkommt
presse
säule säule also hier muss auf jeden
fall die heute drin sein damit steht er
als ehre macht das mal mit der holzteile
noch ganz viel erde für oben für die
dachte das sind
ich brauche morgens erde was ich kann
die erde geben wo bist du ja ok warte
hier hast du ihm wo madl oder so in
kisten oder so oder hast du es mit dem
ton mit dem mit dem holzdeck schon
gemacht
das sieht das runter gehen ich hab's
gemacht in holzbalken zeit übrigens
dingsda hingeschmissen weil man sieht
das wasser ja mach das so wie bei den
sachen die ich da schon für dich tun
sein
in schwerin
immer zwei tief richtung na ja doch zwei
tief da muss einfach gras drüber
ja er habe ich schon richtig gemacht und
jetzt das falsche mit dem holz auch
selbst gut jasnaja muss nur in wasser
holen so und marvel müssen wir aufholen
habe ich doch schon alles mayele seite
ist doch fehlt noch okay stimmt hier
muss doch mal rauskommen ja ich setze da
allerdings langsam aber bitteschön das
erste haustier oder finde das passt
eigentlich mit dem kabel oder ich meine
wenn wir jetzt solarwerte haben dann
glas daneben ich finde das wird richtig
geil dafür dass allem anfangs meinten
dass aus dem niveau vor
sorge weil bei mir sich einfach alles
was ich beruhigt da wir bauen jetzt samt
dass der gäste vergeben fällt aber egal
bei mir sind die leute auch nicht wegen
bauen sondern wegen dem wasser in
spanien wie sie zu beschützen wird kann
ich fast traurig sein
es liegt halt alles nur an deinem körper
also die wahl nur weil die leute mich
also geil finde ich sogar szene genau
weil ich diese currywurst beim
enkeltrick es mit den richtig deswegen
sagt ok ich muss jetzt erde sammeln okay
ach du hier drin dass alles schön ich
brauch glas habe ich hab nur ein wasser
ist traurig einen wassereimer beiden ist
öl aber ich weiß nicht was ich machen
soll was für öl was für böhmer sprach
ich mit öl was für übergewicht was was
pflanzen du hier wieder für ein scheiß
an am fluss evros angepflanzt fluss ja
wir wollten noch so eine große farm
jetzt mache ich einfach was fressen habe
kurz die opfer wir haben daraus jetzt
auch noch so dinge
das sieht ja geil los was dieses braune
dingsda ich hab ein bisschen der erwerb
seite dran gemacht und vielleicht bis
abwechslung schadet nicht ja mach das
mal noch über woanders für roth ist noch
älter ist echt cool aus unser haus wird
was ja das wird was
das wird das wirklich machen auch später
im weg zur stadt und so sollen mit
laternen und kies und alles ja alles
richtig schlimm ja leute da seht ihr mal
ja der könnte man es als lange währt
wird endlich gut wir sind besser und
hätten wir uns alle so gedrängt und so
und hätten wir das wirklich angenommen
dieses ganze bedrängnis dann wären jetzt
gar nicht dann wäre es jetzt ich alles
so schön hätten wir bestimmt schon zehn
milliarden verschiedene wenn maschinen
gebaut aber es war nicht so schön wer
und was a machine manchmal leben kann
dass ich jetzt mal leben muss mit fit
zum londoner haus gemacht mit dem wasser
er setzt sich kommt bisschen krank aus
schöneck sehr gut ich mache es einfach
zauberisch ich freue mich kein trinken
hier das traurig fand sauber an die
zauberte scheiße server tisch
vier obsidian zwei diamanten und ein
buch guck mal online blog drin da unten
ja egal
nein das passt ja der duisburger zeit
was ich mache den weg ich kann sich
haben
was das mal bilder von unten
als ich brauche ich verrate dann das ist
verrat nicht nehmen die diamanten
einfach für das ticket für das ding für
den wir haben ja schon ranken paar
kummer
wer mich schon ranken oh ja auch nicht
schlecht halbherr reimann ist ein coupon
ein cockpit das meisten hier bitte gut
wie viel hast du ich hab noch eins jetzt
ziemlich schwer zu machen
nein einfach nur im backofen rein muss
unser ganzes zuckerrohr eigentlich hin
jetzt ihr gestecktes capo caccia oder
sowas
so haben wir in unser ganzes zuckerrohr
eigentlich dass da draußen noch liegen
wir hatten wir noch weizen der trainer
dazu dem brot ausmachen können da hätten
wir hätten wir hätte hätte fahrradkette
so sieht sich aus respekt zu haben ich
jetzt total behindert dem ich kein
zuckerrohr doch der befehl letztes
geholt oder immer so auf die zeit
hast du vielleicht irgendwas oder habe
ich da schon zu büchern gemacht das
papier keine ahnung
dann sei das der schon zu papier
gebracht habe und ich einfach das papier
konnte ich sehe da europapier papiere
und das leder wo ich denn das leder
ich finde echt gar nichts mehr